what do you attribute the kind of
Fascination that people have if the time
travel aspects as you guys show are
really not possible in the classic sense
and the Interstellar movie sense so to
speak
um what why do you think people are so
fascinated and why do you think that
people use this as a as a plot device so
frequently that it's almost become kind
of a a Trope in a sense that people
really look look to wormholes to solve a
lot of problems and and movie plot
devices yeah well we
I mean the speed of light is
tough I mean it doesn't allow us to go
too far so it's not only a good idea
it's the law right yeah it's the law and
and it's uh
well
I think authors like to go outside the
the realm of ordinarily established laws
of physics they
usually the the statement is oh well now
we that's what we think now maybe in the
future we'll realize there is a way to
go around it and that may well be true
so it might well be true that we find a
way to around but going around this it's
a very serious change to the loss of
physics so I I I personally would bet
very strongly against actually I
remember the the
a few years ago there was an experiment
claiming that the neutrinos traveled
faster yeah the Opera experiment that's
right
yeah so I met one of my neighbors and so
you see you know relativity is wrong and
so on
so I said okay fine I bet you thousand
dollars that this experiment will go
away
he didn't want to take them
financially wise uh
and yeah I mean it is possible
everything is possible but there are
some things that are more unlikely than
than others yeah a lot of times we talk
on this channel and we have talked about
you know theories of everything which I
definitely want to get into uh with you
as well I can't miss the opportunity to
discuss it but you know oftentimes this
kind of uh perception that such things
are not really falsifiable or not
testable and so why should we kind of
expend time energy money which is so
finite in in value in in amount but
infinite in value what are kind of some
of the motivations to study these things
when you know for example some of the
criticism you know on the internet of
the of the recent humanly traversable
Wormhole theory is that you know we
don't even know if the Randall sundrome
cosmology model five or whatever even
exists and there's no evidence for that
so why study you know kind of an edifice
that's built upon something which may
not even exist
right right right so here here we we are
exploring not the the things that nature
exists but possible Natures that are
consistent with the loss of the general
principles of physics or general
relativity and special relativity Etc
quantum mechanics
um with the goal of just understanding
what is possible the goal is not so it's
not so much to go and build and look for
this Wormhole it's just well
that paper was just a fine exercise but
the main main goal is to I think the
main goal is to understand black holes
better Quantum aspects of black holes
with the goal of understanding why but
how quantum gravity works so black holes
are an interesting problem because they
force us to think about cutting graph in
interesting ways and and if um but does
that not presuppose that there exists a
a theory of everything in other words is
it mandatory certainly it seems that
um wormholes at least non-uh Simply
Connected regions are permissible In
classical gr but certainly to have the
Wormhole as described uh in the paper
seems to rely on on Quantum processes as
you as you very rightfully explained but
um but I want to ask maybe a deeper
question which is kind of your opinion
on theories of everything in general
which is that you know do we need a
Theory of Everything Is it mandatory
that we have yeah I I don't like to
match the world Theory of Everything
I didn't use it no but I I think what we
need is a theory of one with the we
would call quantum gravity so quantum
mechanics of space-time or a theory of
quantum space time
and this is needed because the current
theorists do not explain what happens in
certain circumstances like what happens
at the very beginning of the Big Bang or
what happens in the interior of black
holes and um we would need that theory
to really put all these principles that
we discussed over the beginning of 20th
century together and
if you call that everything yeah that's
uh yeah of everything that we learned in
the 20th century general relativity and
quantum physics
um
the formalism of quantum field Theory
came from putting together quantum
mechanics and special relativity
and I think we like to put in general
relativity and and
this is a very very constrained
structure so the question I mean one
question that I think that the fact that
we need this theory is clear uh you
could question whether we will ever get
this Theory without doing experiments
so I think this is a valid question now
why why do we think we might get
there like this is that
well we have some examples of candidate
theories that are mostly like we should
really think of them a theories under
construction like string theory and so
on which uh
which have lots of mathematical
intricacies and error put together
managed to put together gravity and
quantum mechanics
we don't know whether it's the Right
theory for nature we don't know if
that's the correct framework to correct
Theory special theories with crime
nature but their goal I think is to is
that by thinking about those theories
you might even be able to abstract some
principles
could be used to describe nature
and in the process people discuss
discover all kinds of relationships
between this series and Mathematics and
other areas of physics and might even uh
and and we now think that gravity and
quantum mechanics are connected in many
different ways and
so perhaps a provocative idea is that
you might be able to build a little toy
universe in a lab so yeah yeah see your
morale A friend of mine has written a
book about a big bang in a little room
which is a wonderful little book